welcome to Bible answers live where
you'll get honest answers to your Bible
questions let's face it it's not always
easy to understand everything you read
in the Bible with 66 books and more than
700 thousand words the Bible can
generate a lot of questions if you'd
like answers to your Bible questions
you've come to the right place now
here's your host pastor Doug Batchelor
president and speaker of amazing facts
now here is an amazing fact it turns out
the fastest bird in the world just got
passed up by a flying mammal that's
right the Brazilian free-tailed bat just
smashed the old record for horizontal
flight beating out the world's fastest
birds for example the common Swift has a
top speed of around 68 miles an hour
a pigeon 77 miles an hour an albatross
79 miles an hour but now researchers
from the ornithology Institute in
Germany have found that Brazilian
free-tailed bats a tiny bat that weighs
about half an ounce can reach a top
speed of 99 miles an hour the team says
that the bats unique ability for sonic
flight seems to stem from its extremely
light frame and larger than average
wings to measure the bat speed they had
to affixed tiny half gram radio
transmitters to a number of the little
bats once these transmitters were
attached the team used a mobile receiver
on a small aircraft to monitor their
speed researchers admit they had trouble
clocking their speeds because those
little critters are fast it's no wonder
they can catch up to 600 insects in a
single night don't worry about the
little experimental bats the
transmitters were designed to fall off
on their own after a few days now keep
in mind this record is for level flight
as opposed to a diving maneuver the
record for the fastest diving speed goes
to the peregrine falcon which can reach
the blinding speed of around 242 miles
an hour but these little bats can fly
faster than a falcon horizontally you
know the Bible says that bats and birds
have nothing on the speed of angels stay
with as friends we're going to learn
more as amazing facts brings you this
edition
of Bible answers live
you're listening to Bible answers live
honest answers to your Bible questions
our phone lines are now open if you have
a Bible related question call us at one
eight hundred
one eight hundred four sixty three
seventy to ninety seven now let's join
our host pastor Doug Batchelor Bible
answers live and phones are live and
this is the most exciting part of the
week for me to be able to just open up
the lines meet new friends and do our
best to ansel answer your Bible
questions if you've got a question
got lots of lines open right now here is
the number again 800 for six three seven
two nine seven that's 800 God says one
more time you ready Paul now good chance
you'll get your question on tonight's
program 800 four six three seven two
nine seven I am pastor Doug Batchelor
and my co-host pastor John Ross has the
night off and so with the help of those
in the studio and the Lord we're gonna
do our best to answer your questions and
we're gonna talk to the Lord right now
Father in Heaven we thank you so much
for this opportunity in this technology
that helps us to make new friends from
around the country and the world and
talk about the Word of God please bless
Lord we pray that we can rightly
communicate the truth and that the truth
will have power to change hearts we pray
this in Jesus name Amen you know friends
I was amazed I've always been kind of
fascinated with bats I went to summer
camp as I was a kid and my name is
Bachelor but you don't spell it ba CH he
spelled my name ba t CH e lor and at
summer camp I would catch bats and they
called me Doug bat catcher
instead of Bachelor and so I've always
been kind of intrigued with bats and so
it was interesting to hear that the
fastest flying critter was not a bird
it's a bat and and it's these uh
free-tailed bats there in Brazil they've
also got the Mexican free-tailed bats
that could probably give them a run for
their money but you know in the Bible
that tells us that angels can travel
much faster you probably already knew
that but
is actually a story that you find in the
Book of Daniel chapter 9 it tells us
that the prophet Daniel was praying and
while he was praying and you can read
the prayer it probably takes about Oh 4
or 5 minutes to read through the prayer
at the end of his prayer it says that
while I was speaking verse 20 while I
was speaking and praying and confessing
my sin and the sin of my people this is
a Daniel 9 verse 20 and presenting my
supplication before the Lord my god for
the holy mountain of my god yes while I
was speaking in prayer the man Gabriel
and that's Gabriel the angel who appears
to Mary about five hundred years later
which tells us that angels don't age
Gabriel who I had seen in the vision at
the beginning being caused to fly
swiftly he reached me about the time of
the evening offering and he informed me
informed me and talked with me and said
Oh Daniel I have now come forth to give
you skill and understanding at the
beginning of your supplication your
prayer the command went out and I've
come to tell you so at the time that
Daniel began to pray God called Gabriel
go help Daniel understand the vision by
the end of Daniels prayer Gabriel was
there and if you think about the
immensity of space angels do not travel
the speed of sound or even the speed of
light they must travel the speed of
thought we don't even have a measurement
for how fast they travel but I'll tell
you they must really be cooking when
they fly because they get across the
cosmos
in just a few moments you know it's good
to know that if we're in trouble and we
pray that God can have an angel at our
side the Bible says he will give his
angels charge over you to bear you up in
your hands lest you dash your foot
against the stone and he hedges us in
with his angels Bible is quite a bit to
say about angels and we have a study
guide that we will send you tonight
about special messages that have come
from angels and it's called angel
messages from space you'd like a free
copy of tonight's lesson a beautifully
illustrated color Bible lesson it's
called angel messages from space it is
free for anyone and here's the number
call 883 five
six seven four seven now this is a
different number from the call and
question number this is the resource
number we also have chaplains standing
by that are willing to pray with you if
you have some special need for prayer at
this number here it is again 808 three
five six seven four seven ask for the
free study guide angel messages from
space telling me you're listening to
Bible answers live alright with that
we're gonna start talking to some of our
friends that are calling in and we've
got Lisa who's calling from Queens New
York Lisa you're on the air with Bible
answers live yes hi how you doing and
good evening to you evening um I have a
question and I've been like even all my
monsters through the week on
masturbation is this in the Bible any
type of way the ungodly well lets it's
obviously I got to be delicate in the
way I answer this question because we
have families and kids listening but you
know Jesus said in oh I think it's
Matthew chapter six that if a man looks
on a woman to lust after her in his
heart that he can commit adultery
without actually committing the act
because of what's happening in the mind
now obviously that principle would be
the same with a man or with a woman and
in so fantasizing about adultery that is
often accompanied with the physical self
gratification that's not being pure of
heart you know the Bible says blessed
are the pure in heart now I recognize a
lot of people struggle with all kinds of
sins and temptations and the Bible says
that God is merciful and we can repent
of our sins and God can change and give
us pure hearts but I think it's pretty
hard to justify biblically that that
would be falling under the criteria
being pure in life and pure in heart and
so you know the sexual activity
biblically is blessed in connection with
a Christian marriage and so
within the sanctity of a marriage so
outside of that you know the Bible
doesn't say anything that approves it so
I don't know I hope that helps a little
bit Lisa it's I appreciate your
questions brought of people that have
wondered and worried about that and you
know it sex is a it's a unique issue
because you God created us with a number
of desires you know we need we have
physical desires for food and if you
don't satisfy that desire you die and
we've got physical desires for shelter
and clothing for warmth and and and
those are you know really important
necessities sex is a very powerful
physical desire but believe it or not
you won't die if you don't satisfy it
it's just a strong constant desire and
God gave that to all people so that you
know of course we'd procreate and
develop families but it's to be realized
within a marriage and anyway I
appreciate your question Lisa and we do
have a sermon online that you can listen
to where it talks about power in purity
and if you go to the amazing facts
website and that address is simply
amazing facts dot o-r-g it's a sermon I
did called the power purity you know I
found a lot of these sermons people copy
and put them on YouTube you could
probably find it there as well with that
thank you for your question we're gonna
talk to Vanessa who is calling from
Atlanta Georgia Vanessa oh you're on the
air with Bible answers live I'm doing
well how are you doing good okay about
this my questions are what is the Bible
say about the voice being the read the
reason being domestic violence abuse
spiritual abuse yes abuse physical abuse
well there's there's really just a
couple of criteria that deal with
divorce in the Bible one of them being
if a person who is married violates the
marriage vows
through adultery and you can find that
in Matthew 19 and it's in the Sermon on
the Mount as well that and you can read
lay like I'll read in Matthew 19 for he
said have you not read he that made them
at the beginning made them male and
female and said for this reason a man
will leave his father and mother and be
joined to his wife and the two shall
become one flesh so they are no longer
two but one flesh and then he goes on to
say they said but Moses said give us a
certificate of divorce and put her away
there's some problem Jesus said Moses
because of the hardness of your hearts
permitted you to divorce your wives but
from the beginning it was not so and I
say to you whoever divorces his wife
except for sexual immorality and marries
another commits adultery and whoever
marries her who is divorced commits
adultery now I want you to notice
divorce is different from separation did
he catch that Vanessa if you're in a
situation where you are being abused you
should separate from that situation God
does not want any person man or woman to
put them in a situation where they're
you know physically at risk you know and
there's other forms of abuse obviously
and you might tell your spouse look
we're not getting back together we're
separated unless you get counseling and
there's some hope to redeem or restore
our relationship and but that doesn't
mean you have to get divorced and get
remarried to someone else so separation
is actually a different issue from
divorce divorce people usually go
through a divorce because they're
putting themselves back on the market to
get remarried see what I'm saying okay
separation yeah we are separating Wow
but things are getting worse so you must
still be in contact if if things are
getting worse
do you have a I'm wondering if you have
a local pastor or somebody that you can
counsel with my pastor No
but I've heard and I know about the
Bible verse dismissed
I'm Angela the woman is guy who's going
to church that's right
there's Bible verses and I know about
the death if you have a death of a
spouse that qualifies you creating
remarry as well as the poetry there's in
adultery that's right and you know there
he got the case where there's an
unbeliever like the Samaritan woman and
she had several husbands and was living
with a man she wasn't married to Jesus
revealed himself to her but I'm sure
that after that she began to follow the
biblical principles you know Vanessa I
would like to recommend we're gonna
offer you a free book tonight it's
called marriage divorce and remarriage
and I wrote this book especially for
people struggling with issues like you
are if you call the resource number you
tell them you're listening to Bible
answers live I will send you a free copy
of the book marriage divorce and
remarriage it covers everything I could
find in the Bible on that subject and it
gives you the principles here is the
number for the book the resource 808
three five six seven four seven
that's 808 three five six seven four
seven tell them you're listening to
Bible answers live and you'd like the
book marriage Atal divorce and
remarriage thank you for your call and
that would free up another line if
somebody has a question they want to
call the number is 800 god says with
that we're going to yes Linda is that
how you say your name from Milwaukee
it's Lena Milwaukee are you on the air
with Bible answers life Milwaukee are
you listening it yeah how do you say
your name I'm Lena I Lena I'm sorry
there was an extra letter in the
screeners and addresses and your
question tonight yes I've been
struggling with an addiction almost my
whole life and I want to know I know God
is a God of love and forgiveness but how
do we know if God will continue to
forgive us
when we know that it's wrong that's one
question and then - well it's really the
same question the Bible I came across a
scripture a few days ago can't remember
where where it says that's what those
who continue to spin when it when they
know it's wrong
yeah that's Hebrews 10 if we continue to
sin willfully after we've received a
knowledge of the truth there's no more
sacrifice for sin that's Hebrews 10 I
think 26 well let me answer your first
question don't give up doing all that
you can do humanly to turn to God for
victory I can't tell you how many times
I quit smoking before I really quit
smoking
it's like Mark Twain said quitting
smoking is easy I've done it a hundred
times but finally by the grace of God I
quit for good and I haven't picked up a
cigarette in 37 years or something so he
can give you the victory don't you know
if some people are struggle with
addictions for years my dad he struggled
with smoking 50 years and he finally
quit no I'm just picking smoking as one
example but any addiction is an
addiction some people struggle with food
addictions and then you know I have
known folks who have battled with that
for 20-30 years and then the Scott gives
them the grace and there's a big change
that comes into their life and they
change your lifestyle and they
everything gets turned around and
they're just so happy people who
struggle with drugs or a variety of bad
habits don't underestimate the power of
God now there's some hope in the Bible
it talks about Mary Magdalene out of
whom God cast Seven Devils and so that
doesn't mean all at once he cast Seven
Devils that means seven times she fell
back into her old patterns and God set
her free so he can do that for you - are
you still with me yes now that verse yes
I just feel dejected and like a failure
where
no you know first of all I I'm not going
to tell you to feel good about doing bad
because we should feel some remorse
about San God some pastors are out there
saying Europe don't feel bad about
saying well Jesus died for our sins it's
serious business but don't be
discouraged because he is graceful and
he's merciful in the very fact that
you're calling means the Holy Spirit's
working in your life it's even the Holy
Spirit that gives us the gift of
conviction now let me read that verse to
you you asked about a verse in Hebrews
10:26 for if we sin wilfully after we
receive a knowledge of the truth there
no longer remains a sacrifice for sin
that word there if we sin wilfully in
Greek that word is if we continue to sin
wilfully now it sounds like you're
regretting your sin and your wanting
victory and deliverance from your sin
now everyone falls and we all slip up
but you're you know it's a different
thing to really be trapped in a pattern
of sin and would it be okay if I just
have a quick prayer of you please yeah
well let's do that right now
Father in Heaven I just want to pray
that you be with Elena and please give
her victory over the struggles in her
life help her not to be discouraged and
know that you are a God of grace and
that a righteous man may fall seven
times and rise again and you can give
her victory and set her free completely
I pray that dub you'll help her to
experience some encouragement and hope
in the next few days and progress in her
walk with you and so just bless her with
your presence and help her to understand
your grace and power I pray in Jesus
name Amen
thank you so much all right hey thank
you you know I'm gonna send you a book
and don't let this title of the book
scare you but if you call the resource
number they're gonna send you a book and
it's called
no turning back and it's gonna just
encourage you and how you can live a
victorious life it's a study guide
called no turning back and I'll give you
a bunch of scriptures to encourage you
there all right hey the number is 883
five six seven four seven now that does
free up another phone call friends and
so if you another line if you want to
call in with your Bible question
the number is 800 God says for the
studio for your question
800 four six three seven two nine seven
and let me see who is lined up next
we're gonna be talking to John calling
from Sacramento California John welcome
to the program oh thank you very much I
really appreciate your program I'm
getting a lot out of it
but I had a question that's been
bothering me and I was wondering if you
might be able to help I know that in the
Bible talks about the creation of man
and that God created man but I'm
wondering who created God can you offer
any insight into that
well my insights will be parallel to the
alternatives in other words I am NOT
going to be able to tell you who created
God because I'd probably have to be God
to do that but let me give you some
things to think about on that line we
could also be asking if nobody created
god if where did anything come from a
matter as far as we know scientifically
does not self create we see nothing in
our observable world where intelligence
creates itself all of the organization
and design that we see in industry the
intelligence of man puts these systems
whether it's a car or factory or
computer we put them together because
there's an outside intelligence that is
developing that and so we can ask the
same question about God at some point we
have to say somewhere something always
must have existed
people who believed in evolution when
you say well where did the world come
from and hang with me for just a moment
I'm gonna give you very simplistic
answers where did the world come from
well the world was formed when our solar
system was formed when our Sun went
spinning out as the Milky Way galaxy was
spiraling through space and it flung off
the nine planets and their moons in our
solar system it's a okay
where our Sun come from well when there
was you know some supernova and it
created this galaxy and where did they
that come or it came from
nebulae exploding and I'm just being I'm
paraphrasing here and you know these gas
particles came together okay where'd the
gas particles come from and you know now
they actually say that the whole
universe was formed by a piece of matter
that was as small as the head of a pin I
mean I've heard all kinds of interesting
theories and and finally every
evolutionist will say we don't know
something always existed because we
matter does not create itself that's you
know we get the laws of thermodynamics
that we observe and so we can either
believe that all of the incredible
beauty organization designs symbiotic
relationships we see in this world all
happen purely by chance or we can and
that and came from matter that always
existed or that there has been an
intelligent God and God says in his word
from everlasting to everlasting I am God
jesus said he is the Alpha and the Omega
there's no beginning or end to God no we
can't comprehend that it just makes our
brain start to boil when we think about
it so I can't tell you where God came
from I can just tell you what the Bible
says is that he always has been
he says I am that I am he is eternal
that's you know makes it mom dip it in
we can't understand that mm-hmm that's
very good thank you very much all right
hey I appreciate your question thank you
very much for calling in all right with
that we're gonna talk next to Timothy
he's been waiting patiently
Timothy calling from a Spring Creek
Nevada thank you for your call doing
well how are you so my question is
what's your viewpoint or your you think
on unwinds writings of amalgamations on
Ellen White's writings of amalgamation
amalgamates efforts over amalgamation
well you have a Bible question for me if
it sounds kind of like out of there
I do well I'll just tell you what the
word of Malaga mayshen means is when you
you biologically try and breed certain
characteristics and hybrids amalgamation
is you can have a Malaga mayshen of c2
where you you take you know a good
zucchini and the bad zucchini you cross
pollinate them you amalgamate you mix
the seed and you end up with an inferior
hybrid and so there is a statement I
know where she says one of the things
that really bothered people before the
flood was the amalgamation of man and
beast some have thought that meant
amalgamation of man with B she didn't
say that an example of an amalgamation
of man in the Bible as tells us that
Goliath had and one verse says it was
his brother in other verse says it was a
son that had six fingers on each hand in
each foot the way that you get that
problem in most cases with an extra
digit is through genetic weakness
through inbreeding and some have
speculated the Philistines were trying
to in breed the Giants of Goliath to
create an army of giants that's
amalgamation and you end up with the
defects through inbreeding she didn't
say the inbreeding of man with bees
there was man and beast and pit bulls
are specifically bred for their jaw
strengths so they can do maximum damage
now did you have a Bible question though
I do evidence or proof or Mike going
towards mom Jesus or is Jesus Michael
the Archangel many of the reformed
theologians and I agree with them
believe that the Chris Stephanie's the
times that Jesus appeared in the Old
Testament when he appeared as the angel
of the Lord to Joshua he said take your
shoes off your feet when it says the
Lord descends from heaven with the shout
of the Archangel the Lord has the shout
Archangel means greatest messenger the
Bible tells us that when Michael stands
up Michael the Archangel that there's a
great time of try
in revelry and that's Daniel 12 in
Revelation 12 you read where the dragon
who is a symbolic name for the devil
goes to war with Michael who is a
symbolic name for Christ Michael and his
angels the dragon at his angels
Jesus is not an angel the name Michael
is one of the pre incarnation names or
titles for Christ the word angel is used
in the Bible for angels for men for God
it just means messenger Angelus in Greek
so yeah Matthew Henry Adam Clarke a
number of the great reformer theologians
believed that Michael was an example of
Jesus being used back then one more
thought on that question Michael we do
have a book and I'll send you a free
copy copy it's called who is Michael the
Archangel so if you don't mind
Timothy go to call the number eight
hundred eight three five six seven four
seven ask for the book who is Michael
the Archangel it's got all the verses
and cross-references in there friends
were going to take a break call back in
with your questions lines open
stay tuned Bible answers live we'll
return in a moment
I really wanted to start a new
devotional habit but life got in the way
next thing I know we're a month into the
new year and I'm like what's the point
of starting then I saw 365 amazing
answers to big Bible questions each day
is a single study so you can start
anywhere on any day and not miss a thing
their crisp clear and enlightening get
yours today by calling 855-578-6767
every bible question you have answered
moves you one step closer to the
fullness of God's will for your life so
what are you waiting for get the answers
you need for a fuller richer more
confident life you're listening to Bible
answers live we still have a few phone
lines open if you have a Bible related
question call us at 1-800-805-3030
for more Bible answers live welcome back
friends if you've tuned in somewhere
along the way this is Bible answers live
one of the biggest interactive Bible
studies in the world and you're invited
to join in we have a couple lines still
open and that number to the studio 800
God says that's because the Bible God's
Word is our source book here 800 4 6 3 7
2 97 and I am Doug Batchelor pastor Ross
is off for the evening and we're gonna
go right back to the phones and be
talking here next let me see hang on
here pastor Ross is in here and so I'm
having to think Daniels been waiting a
long time we're gonna talk to Daniel
calling from West Chester New York
Daniel you're on the air with Bible
answers live yes what people believe the
Sikhs I had some neighbors when I lived
in New Mexico they were just very kind
lovely people it is an religion that's a
lot more native to India you know it's
not really a Bible question so I can't
give you a chapter and verse on the Sikh
movement but it's you know it was
articulated in their scriptures from
their guru they believed in faith and
meditation one creator unity equality
for all mankind and they do somewhat
believe in a righteousness by works you
know
one of the best things you could do is
if you go to just the Wikipedia and you
type in Sikhism
they've got articles on the religion you
know typically we take a Bible question
take three minutes to answer a Bible
question I'd have two to do their
religion justice I'd probably have take
a little more time than that and you
know I hate to do that to anybody's
faith and just kind of summarize it in a
sentence or two but yeah it is I'm
thinking the Sikhism is probably the
third largest or fourth largest religion
in India after Buddhism Hinduism rather
and Islam Buddhism in Sikhism and it's
spreading to different parts of the
world they've got several temples even
here in North America so yeah and I say
there man I think are always supposed to
have a knife on them a sacred knife got
it some interesting beliefs and there's
a headgear that they wear that's
connected with their beliefs but dia
take a look at that online Daniel you'll
probably find more information on that
all right we're gonna talk next with Ron
who's calling from Waterford North
Dakota Ron you're on the air with Bible
answers live Ron evening yes I got a
question if someone takes their own life
and is their eternal separation from God
will a person automatically be lost
because he got two kinds of people he
got saved and lost in the judgment and
you're asking will a person be lost if
they commit suicide well I guess if a
believer chose to take his own life
where he'd be separated you know well
I've got to always be careful I'm gonna
be right up front and tell you why I got
to be careful answering that question
everybody listening out there knows
somebody that probably committed suicide
and you got to be very careful about
saying everybody who's committed suicide
is automatically lost because there are
rare cases where a person may have been
does overwhelmed with
physical pain or grief that we can't
comprehend they serve the Lord with
their lives there's even a few hymns in
the typical Christian hymnal that were
written very famous hymns by someone who
committed suicide because they struggled
with depression that could have been a
chemical problem and you know God knows
those things but so I need to just make
that clear most cases I'm afraid suicide
is a result of a person who has lost
faith and they've lost hope and the
Bible says without faith it's impossible
to please God were saved by faith and by
grace through faith and so you know it's
not a good indicator if the Bible says
thou shalt not kill and the last act of
a person's life is self murder that
would not for be a good foreboding so
you know I think in most cases it
doesn't look good but I I remember doing
a funeral for a young lady that teenager
became discouraged took some pills and
then realized what she'd done and called
and said look I've taken some pills I
don't want to die and you know who knows
what happened on her way to the hospital
but they tried to pump her stomach and
they could not save her she repented of
her decision to commit suicide her death
certificate will probably read suicide
but who knows she may have repented and
God could have forgiven her like the
thief on the cross so we've got to be
careful to automatically say everybody
who commits suicide is they go to
they're gonna be lost and that said
Samson in the Bible you still there on
Samson one of the last acts of his life
was to lay his life down he knew full
well he was going to die when he pushed
the temple down but he was filled with
the Spirit of God to do that and he is
listed in Hebrews 11 as those among the
faithful and so we'll probably see
Samson in heaven but some might classify
him as a suicide he really laid down his
life to defeat God's people from their
enemies and I think they're getting
ready to execute him he knew that so
anyway you can I know people that have
sacrificed their lives they
who willingly died to save someone else
you know would you say they're a suicide
it's a little different there Jesus he
sacrificed his life to save others so if
anyone out there is thinking of suicide
don't do it because it's probably not
gonna bode very well most people who
commit suicide are gonna wake up in the
wrong resurrection people commit suicide
because they get tired of life thinking
things are somehow get better by killing
themselves and they're gonna find out
when they wake up things have gotten
very bad and there's no hope who was it
Solomon that says in Ecclesiastes a
living dog is better than a dead lion
where there is life there's hope
and so hang on my mother used to
struggle with suicide I'll just admit
admit it and tell you she'd called me
after I became a Christian tell me she
was struggling and I said well mom once
you commit suicide you can never change
your mind and you'll lose all your
options and who knows what you're gonna
miss tomorrow and her curiosity always
got the best of her and she thought can
I make it one more day
and sometimes a good night's sleep can
change everything
so if anyone out there is toying with
suicide just forget about it it won't
make things better
where there's life there's hope they
hope that helps a little bit Ron
appreciate your call and with that we're
gonna talk next to Henry by the way line
is open then we got a couple lines open
804 6 3 7 2 97 with your questions
talking to Henry on line 8 Bronx New
York on the air when Jesus Christ comes
back and saves and they're pregnant it's
a nine month government heaven all right
first of all and that's a valid question
someone asked me what will happen to a
woman who is pregnant if Jesus comes
I said she'll be delivered first that's
a play on words but
I believe that there are of course
children in heaven and the Bible tells
us they're young infant children because
it says in Isaiah that in heaven the
infant child will play on the whole of
the venomous serpent but it will not
hurt them so there's infants in heaven I
just think that when a woman who is you
know fully pregnant with a child and the
Lord comes probably right then the
Angels will place the baby in her arms
so all right you know it's not a problem
for God I'm sure she'll have her child
in heaven and Lord may accelerate the
gestation period just like he made Adam
Adam wasn't made a baby he was made
full-grown man God can just at the
Second Coming say all right here's your
baby and enjoy enjoy the glorified baby
and glorified body and you caught up to
meet the Lord in the air so it'll be
something like that
sometimes people say well what's gonna
happen to those that are on the
International Space Station when Jesus
comes and I get some very interesting
questions hey thank you very much Henry
I do have a lesson I'll send you a free
copy if you'd like that talks about the
second coming and if you call the
resource line and say you'd like the
amazing facts lesson about the ultimate
deliverance talks about the second
coming of Jesus and I told you a lady
will be delivered when the Lord comes if
she's pregnant
the ultimate deliverance we'll send you
a free copy of that just call 808 three
five six seven four seven and we
appreciate your call with that we're
gonna be talking next to Alesha who is
calling from Huntsville Alabama
listening on w jou Alicia you're on the
air with Bible answers live get real
close to your phone you're all the way
out there in Alabama yes and your
question tonight I was wondering how
many consider the first and if so how
many proceeded most people believe that
the sanctuary tabernacle or temple was a
temple because the presence of God
dwelled there they met with God they're
the Ark of the Covenant
there it had the same main three
compartments it had the courtyard it had
the holy place and it had the inner
sanctum known as the Holy of Holies
you find those same three rooms in the
permanent temple that Solomon built that
was destroyed later by Nebuchadnezzar
and then when Ezra and Nehemiah came
back from the Babylonian captivity they
rebuilt that temple that was later
embellished and modified by Herod the
Great so there were three temples the
first one was a mobile home it was a
portable temple they traveled they take
it down they'd set it up but it met the
criteria of being a place where God met
with the people a place where they
offered sacrifice so I think it does
fall in the category of being what you'd
call a temple it was just very uniquely
designed to be portable because they
were a nation of pilgrims at the time
though it was built it took a long time
to get it built because they'd start on
it and then the government and Persia
changed and they had a stop order issued
and then they gave it another start
order and but it was built and you can
read about that if you read the books of
Ezra Nehemiah and matter-of-fact trying
to member the profit that prophesied
that the glory of that third temple was
going to be greater than the glory of
the first two Haggai he said the glory
of this house would be even greater
because Jesus actually taught in that
third temple that was built during the
time of Ezra and Nehemiah it went
through a great renovation under Herod
the Great he was he was a king that was
a real dichotomy he he killed the babies
in Bethlehem but he loved to build
temples so we'll figure that out anyway
yeah and matter of fact you can remember
when the Jesus came to Jesus and Jesus
had destroyed this temple made with
hands and in three days I'll make one
without hands and they said forty in six
years this temple was under construction
how will you raise it up in three days
that's because the renovation project of
Herod the Great had taken over 40 years
so hey I appreciate your question no
I've got a lesson I'll be happy to send
you on the temple and it's called God
drew the plans and it talks about the
Bible temple and what its function was
you'll love this lesson just call the
resource line 808 3-5 anyone out there
if you'd like to better understand the
Bible temple it's a beautifully
illustrated lesson as all the scriptures
fun to read eight hundred eight three
five six seven four seven ask for the
lesson God drew the plans you can learn
about salvation from that temple and if
you have a phone call we still have some
lines open that number is 888.259.3826
that everyone needs to go through some
form of purging that's where you get the
word purgatory some sort of fire of
purging to purify you before you really
fit for heaven and some may need more
than others and you don't really find
that in the Bible the matter of fact I
understand that the Catholics I think a
recent Pope even dismissed their belief
in purgatory they they said yeah so you
don't find it in the Bible some have
wondered about the parable of the rich
man and Lazarus that the rich man was in
purgatory but it doesn't
the event and so that is really if in my
humble opinion a man-made doctrine that
you don't find now as far as the people
that jumped over off the World Trade
Center would it be a suicide you know I
don't think so I think that there are
some people that are you know if you're
on a building that's on fire and you've
got the choice of jumping and burning to
death and he chose to jump uh uh you
know I think that's actually a same
decision they understand that several
people they took the hands of others and
they said look we'll do it together and
just then they knew that there was no
hope coming and they were either going
to you know suffer the agony of the fire
or and you know instinctively when
you're burning you withdraw from it it's
just a physical reaction so I'd never
accuse anyone that jumped from a burning
building of suicide but he I hope that
helps a little bit we appreciate your
question David with that we're gonna
talk next to April who's calling from
Loma Linda California April you're on
the air with Bible answers live people
it's great thank you so much you my
question is what is the biblical
definition of a fool and that may be
asked a little too narrowly a little too
simply maybe we want to cover the topic
it may be too difficult you know because
I know there are quite a few references
to either fools or foolishness and if
you could just speak to it in whatever
way you choose I would appreciate that
but I thought I would start with that
now what is or a biblical definition of
a fool and I'll listen to you off the
air and thank you again very much I'm
enjoying this program well great thank
you so much for your call that's very
kind of you April and you know it's
interesting because Jesus said don't
call your brother a fool and then Jesus
uses that same term at least in the King
James Version many times he often says
Oh fools and slow of heart to believe
and he calls us drives and the Pharisees
fool when he said don't call anyone fool
or you're in danger of the judgment I
think Jesus was using the word don't
tell anybody that they're worthless
there are different words and and so
sometimes the word for a fool is coming
from the definition of somebody that is
being simple-minded
and you know let's face it you know the
Bible talks about foolishness is in the
heart of a child
and sometimes children they're young
they do silly things and the
simple-minded things and you know Christ
often rebuked people for their not
thinking things through doing foolish
things when Jesus says you don't call a
person a fool in Matthew chapter 5 he's
saying don't say any tell anybody that
they're worthless and so it's I think
really a different emphasis that he's
making there um and you know Bible's
pretty clear it tells us that the Fool
has said in his heart there is no God it
is a foolish thing and that is suicide
to deny the existence of God especially
when there is so much evidence for God
in the natural world around us
I appreciate your call April and hope
that helps a little bit we do still have
a line or two open eight hundred four
six three seven two nine seven talking
next to Eugene calling from Pontiac
Michigan Eugene you're on the air with
Bible answers live hi bad connection
here and can you hear it cheap phone um
speaking of fools I was a complete fool
my question is lady neighbors mine very
much so
enough so that moved out because I
wanted scriptures the idea of when you
offend someone extremely bad you know
what do you do
alright that is that's a great question
and it's a practical question and don't
feel like you're alone Eugene is
probably nobody listening right now that
hasn't said something foolish
and I just recoiled with regret when I
think about the silly careless things
I've said or done to offend people
I can't count them even david said you
know am i my transgressions are more
than the hairs of my head and when you
offend someone and you want to
communicate sorrow for that if they'll
let you approach them then you you can
go to them jesus said if you offend your
brother and you read in matthew 18 a
whole criteria about how to be
reconciled go to them alone and
apologize sincerely and you can be
specific and just say you're very sorry
and they hope you'll hope they'll
forgive you
maybe you can't approach them in person
you can write a kind note and say it
would mean so much I'm so sorry I
offended you and you know what I said or
did was so foolish and thoughtless and
and you know it's like with the Lord we
repent of our sins we confess our sins
with God and it's appropriate to repent
and confess the Bible says in the book
of James confess your faults to one
another and pray for one another
sometimes you know I do not oh you might
send the wrong message if this is a
young lady and and but sometimes if you
do something you can give a person a
little gift and say please forgive me
and this is you know I need a peace
offering and it shows if that you care
but you know those those are the typical
things you do and and if they don't
forgive you you know you tell the Lord
and you've done all you can do humanly
to clear your soul and then you move on
you ask God to forgive you and and you
move on from there whenever you think
about it sometimes you'll have a painful
memory and you'll have some regrets but
you don't let the devil beat you up
if we confess our sins he is faithful
and just to forgive us our sins and to
cleanse us from all unrighteousness
that's first John chapter one talking
next to Amanda calling from Warren
Michigan Amanda you're on the air with
answers live hi I actually had a quick
question about meat eating there are
specific kinds of meat in the Bible that
tell us about as far as there's meats
that are an abomination to us and then
there's meats that you can eat yes I'm
bad that just that just confused me just
a little bit because there's a lot of
meats that are unclean yeah well most of
the things that the Bible describes as
unclean are not a problem for most
people I mean the Bible says you're not
supposed to eat buzzards and you're not
supposed to eat camel now the people in
the Middle East still do eat camel
that's why Jesus strain and that and
swallow a camel right but people that
eat well biblically for an animal and
you'll find these criteria in talks
about it in Genesis a little but mostly
it's in Leviticus you can look at me
Leviticus 11 for a mammal to be clean
biblically it needed two criteria one
was it needed to be an animal that was a
vegetarian it ate grass and it chewed
its cud and then I needed a cloven hoof
that's where it's got that the double
split hoof you know like a cow or a deer
or a goat or a sheep they're all
considered clean animals if it was a
bird it needed to be a foraging bird
like a chicken or a turkey or a pigeon
the birds of Kerry and vultures and
crows and those things are unclean
scavengers were unclean and if it's a
fish it needed two things to be clean it
needed to be fins and scales a trout and
bass and tuna would be considered clean
the other things God said well first of
all the the ideal diet for man isn't is
a vegetarian diet that's what Adam and
Eve were in the Garden of Eden that's
what we're gonna eat again in heaven
says we'll eat from the tree of life and
you can remember where Daniel in Chapter
one he and his friends said we not gonna
eat the Babylonian food because it was
unclean and at the end of 10 days they
were tested and they found to be
healthier and ten times wiser than all
of the other candidates that had been
eating from the Royal Babylonian cafe
yuria so you know there's this principal
officer the Bible our bodies to the
temple of the Holy Spirit and we got to
care for our bodies I've been a
vegetarian so you can tell I'm a little
bit radical I've been a vegetarian for
38 years and I'm doing pretty good I can
out run most teenagers and I'm almost 60
and I have six and a half grandkids so
the idea that you can't be healthy and
be a vegetarian is a myth people say oh
you're not gonna get enough protein you
eat a peanut butter jelly sandwich you
can get plenty of protein in this you
get protein plenty of places so all
right now I'm off my hobby horse did
that make sense yes it does thank you
and I want it actually I just had one
quick question okay I actually I heard
you were in Michigan Oh a few months ago
yeah will you be coming back to Michigan
I'm sure I will but I don't have a date
yet but if you check the track of us on
the amazing facts website or go to my
Facebook page
we'll try and let you know when we're
going I've been going here about every
year to four years got some great people
out there hey by the way I want to offer
you a free lesson that talks about these
health laws that are in the Bible it's
called God's free health plan I'll send
your free copy Amanda just call 808
three five six seven four seven and it's
called God's free health plan thank you
for calling and let me see I'm gonna
talk we'll probably get time for maybe
one more call here gonna talk to Karen
who is listening on line eight Karen
you're on the air and we've got about a
minute can I help you yes on the chapter
the verse that says to be absent from
the body is to be present with the Lord
isn't it closer to biblical but he that
that whole chapter is talking about how
to live sinless during this life well
some have wondered if when he says right
well yeah you some it I'm a green there
are some that when they read the verse
and you find this in first Corinthians
chapter 5 they're taught there they're
connecting it we're with Paul talks
about living for the spirit and not for
the flesh
being absent from the body means I'm not
living for the flesh I'm not gonna live
for the carnal nature I'm gonna live for
the spiritual nature and be present with
the Lord
but Paul seems to be really talking
about when the Lord comes and will be in
God's presence meaning when a believer
dies their next conscious thought is the
presence of the Lord now we got a whole
lesson that talks about that just to go
to amazing facts and you can read are
the dead really dead and it addresses
that verse friends the beautiful music
is chasing us off the air you can learn
more by going to amazing facts dot o-r-g
and remember Jesus is the truth
thank you for listening to today's
broadcast
we hope you understand your Bible even
better than before Bible answers live is
produced by amazing facts a faith-based
ministry located in Sacramento
California
can't get enough amazing facts Bible
study you don't have to wait until next
week to enjoy more truth filled
programming visit the amazing facts
media library at aft vor G at aft vor G
you can enjoy video and audio
presentations as well as printed
material all free of charge
24 hours a day seven days a week right
from your computer or mobile device
visit aft vor G are you wondering what
lies ahead in human history or what the
recent world events are harbingers of
the end are you ready for the coming
crisis landmarks of prophecy offers
clear answers to your most pressing
questions presented by Pastor Doug
Batchelor landmarks of prophecy is a
contemporary video Bible study adventure
designed for today's audiences
presenting the landmark themes of the
Bible and a bright and compelling way
helping you understand the Bible better
and giving you knowledge to face the
future with confidence landmarks of
prophecy contains over 30 hours of
exciting video presentations on six DVDs
plus bonus question and answer sessions
giving you keen insight into what lies
next in human history if you'd like
practical tools to help you thrive and
survive in the here and now get
landmarks of prophecy start your epic
Bible study adventure with landmarks of
prophecy today by calling
if you'd like to enhance your study of
God's Word
visit our website at WWF AG 0 RG and
sign up for our free Bible study course
and make sure to check out our online
bookstore at AF bookstore comm which
offers thousands of inspiring books DVDs
and more to help you get the most out of
God's Word to take advantage of the
offers you've heard on this broadcast
call us at $887 RG did you enjoy this
program make sure to tell your family
and friends tune in next time for more
Bible answers live honest and accurate
answers to your Bible questions